um but tim you know the facebo uh
twitter
has permanently suspended project
veritas twitter account
the official comment that twitter gave
cnn
uh reporter brian fung of cnn business
is they said that we have uh published
people's private information twitter did
not say
that i misinformation or fake news no no
they said the reason that we were
suspended is because we're doxing people
project veritas is publishing people's
private information
the evidence of that was us doing a
routine tv doorstop that is to say
you know television reporters go outside
someone you know someone's driveway cnn
does it all the time like they do
the memers didn't cnn do that with that
old woman yes
they keep yes and that tweet and and you
could actually see the numbers on her
on her house so it doesn't it's
completely illogical
because uh up i mean but that's that's
censoring that's the reality
but but but here's the interesting part
and i have the documents in front of me
because i want to get
my facts correct brian fung of cnn says
that we
were repeated violation of the company's
quote anti-doxing policies
but then but then just sunday uh the
host's name was
anna cabrera was on with brian stelter
and she
said that project veritas was removed
from misinformation so cnn's own
reporters are contradicting each other
they're just making stuff up
so what you're saying is you're going to
get a retracto out of this i'm we have
our lawyer has sent a letter to cnn
corporate
uh david vigilante is the general
counsel of cnn
and we are going to get a retractor
retracto the correction alpaca
he's coming at you it sounds like it
wasn't so much that you guys got busted
for doxing but that it was the who you
were doxxing because wasn't it somebody
that was high profile
so this is a little nuanced but i think
it's important that we take your
audience through the facts because i
think it's important
because i think twitter has crossed a
rubicon here that they have not
previously crossed i mean look at the
hunter biden stuff man
they suppressed a very relevant news
story to help someone win a presidential
presidential election that is true i
mean these people are evil man that is
true so what happened here was
uh we i don't know if you've ever
experienced this but
when you are flagged twitter gave us the
option it said
uh you can simply get your account
reinstated at project veritas by
deleting this tweet
they want us to delete the tweet the
video of my reporter christian hartsock
with a camera and a flag mic you could
see the flag mic there's no hidden
camera recording here
in in a street on a sidewalk outside the
house of
facebook vice president was this public
property
what was his name guy rosen was this
public property this was a
public street a residential street and
his residence
and we're following the lead of cnn cnn
goes and door stops people local tv news
so i
so christian hartsock asks guy rosen for
comment uh on a
this is maybe the biggest public policy
story of our of our lives
we're not confronting a private citizen
we're con he's a private he's vice
president of facebook
and then twitter says you need to take
down this video clip
off twitter but i decided i'm not going
to do that
tim i would be against my conscience i'm
going to appeal it i knew it was a risk
and usually when you appeal that takes a
week or two to do and then in the middle
of the day twitter got bombarded with
phone calls by the new york
times cnn and everyone else and twitter
changed their minds it said nope we've
changed our mind
we're now going to ban project veritas
forever permanently suspended for some
reason
my personal account was reinstated it
doesn't make any sense
because both me and project veritas
tweet the same stuff pressure
that's just media it's it's this is what
the the game is for these uh
i want to call them journalists these
are activists because i i broke a story
i think it was a year and a half ago
where someone someone who worked at
a major bank leaked to me internal
documents
about i think we actually uh uh i think
we may have talked about this after the
fact
yeah they leaked me these documents and
it was basically showing that this bank
had banned
the uh well i got to be very careful
here it appeared to be
that certain right-wing individuals had
their accounts closed
because an email from a journalist said
why are you supporting white supremacy
or something to that effect
so what they do is a real journalist is
going to email someone and say
you know a story came out and you know
actually i i got to say this there's
literally no news in
finding out that someone has a bank
account and then emailing the bank and
saying why does this person have a bank
account right
we know why people have bank accounts
what they do is they contact the bank
they the email then says something like
this individual
has been accused of being a white
supremacist why do
you support white supremacy the bank
gets the message it's mafioso they're
basically saying
we are going to write a story claiming
you support white supremacist
organizations
and then the bank says oh we don't we we
banned those people and then the
activists pretending to be journalists
go ah
okay great getting financial
institutions or other companies to
destroy their enemies
so it's not too dissimilar you uh james
are one of the i think veritas is one of
the very few actual
news organizations i i look i think
there's a lot of news outlets there's a
lot of good journalists
and they work hard and they do well but
you look at how awful things have gotten
with these major corporate news outlets
there's no risk to the establishment to
the corporate
uh powers to the special interests from
cnn or the new york times
right i mean very little yeah but but
it's like you were saying
these people are looking over their
shoulders not knowing who is going to
hold them accountable by either
recording their
unethical behaviors and exposing them
doing wrong they don't know who that's
going to be and so they're worried about
it and they're worried about you
getting rid of you will make their lives
very i think there's a psychological
like i say right now as i speak if there
are coders engineers
wherever they may be silicon valley when
they do their whatever they do that's
unethical or at least dishonest i know
they're private companies they can do
whatever they want constitutionally but
there's that little thought inside their
head like the jury on your shoulder
sort of worried deterred maybe maybe
someone's observing me do this thing
but what's most interesting about this
situation that where project veritas was
permanently suspended was
twitter changed their mind tim just as
you said once they got bombarded with
all that pressure from new york times
and cnn being like what's the deal
are they suspended permanently or not
and someone high up at twitter said
nope we're going to suspend them forever
and that shows me that the washington
post and the new york times
and and cnn actually have tremendous
power and jeff bezos
who is whatever he is a trillionaire
billionaire trillion dollar market cap
one of the wealthiest men in the history
of the world
is most proud of his ownership of that
woke click
bait rag washington post that's his
crowning achievement in life so
i i actually am not one of those people
who say
these these companies cnn has tremendous
power
to get twitter to change their mind by
making a phone
call think about it cnn spreads baseless
theories
they they eat human brains they dox
people they even had an article not so
long ago that was titled quote how cnn
found the reddit user behind the trump
wrestling
gif yep where they what's the date on
that one what's the date on that one
july 5th 2017. wow where they knowingly
went after someone because of that
famous gift that
donald trump tweeted and they said
publicly
apologize right now or we're going to
doxx they said promise
never to do it again exactly otherwise
we'll release your privacy
and this is the organization that's
spearheading the censorship movement
that never gets called out for their
baseless theories for their fake news in
their lives even the new york times
yesterday we were talking about a
specific story
where the new york times was caught
fabricating the story
about the fire extinguisher killing and
and and beating today
or as a capital police officer at the
very least getting burned by their
sources
and refusing to correct until a month
later exactly and then now today
they also have another another article
that's titled unfettered conversations
are taking place on clubhouse talking
about how
it's dangerous this new kind of platform
that's rising in popularity because
they don't know how to deal with
harassment misinformation and quote
privacy can can i point out the the
beautiful irony
of was it anna cabrera i think you said
was that was that anna cabrera
saying that you were suspended
permanently for misinformation
and that statement itself is
misinformation it's it i mean i have the
two states of fire trucks
by the way we're going to get our lawyer
we could always just sue cnn we've seen
the new york times we'll talk about that
in a minute but that i've got two
statements from cnn in front of me right
now one is from
brian fung cnn business who's actually a
pretty nice i think he's a serious
reporter
and he says that veritas was suspended
for quote
threats of sharing other people's
private information i have wait wait
threats
this is threats of sharing other
people's private information
literally what cnn did luke just cited
that story from them and then i have a
statement from anna cabrera this is on
the air with brian stelter on sunday
quote twitter has suspended the account
of project veritas
i'm quoting her now so forgive it's not
my words forgive me
quote a conservative actionist uh
activist organization at least that's
how they
they couch themselves i have never in my
life
referred to myself as a conservative
activist not once i was swear to it
under oath in a defamation lawsuit
against cnn
unless they retract that and then she
goes on quote this is a much broader
crackdown by social giants on accounts
promoting misinformation
so our general counsel has just sent a
letter to david vigilante
today i have the letter in front of me
signed a failure to retract will sue
by the way these organizations are used
to throwing the spear
at uh civilian innocent people um
they're not used to being
the spear being thrown at them i've sued
the new york times for defamation
in in the new york supreme court and
we're going to get past motion to
dismiss
in a lawsuit we talked about this last
time you and i talked about this
we need to sue the [ __ ] out of them and
and and i'm not doing it to harass i'm
doing it because that's justice if you
lie if you intentionally
disregard the truth that's called actual
malice i'm a public figure
you can't under the law of new york
state
intentionally lie we'll get past motion
to dismiss
and then you get into depositions that
means i put dean back k
executive editor of the new york times
in a chair and he's required by the law
to answer my questions under oath
not only that but isn't there an
opportunity for discovery maybe get
access to discovery
depositions interrogatories they are
required
to answer my questions when i confront
dean beckham the street in los angeles
that's the executive era of the new york
times
he just ran away and laughed maniacally
but when the judge says no you're you
are
you have to answer project veritas's
questions why did you intentionally lie
about james o'keefe
we have so many lawsuits tim that
that our lawyer we i just think we're
going to start suing people
i think it's time because you can't you
can't defame
people and get away with it anymore so
long as people don't fight back
you can but not seems like they picked a
fight they're not you know
it's really expensive the problem with
litigation is that
each of these lawsuits is a million
bucks but we talked about this last time
remember we said someone should start a
non-profit and just start suing people
yes who lie well that that might
actually just be project
you know one-third of our budget at this
point you know you'll make money on it
yeah the people's defamation defense
fund right exactly
perfect just get a big fund and then
track when you know the issue is there
are a lot of people now who are finding
themselves in the public sphere
who have small careers as personalities
pundits and journalists
they can't go up against the new york
times small individual
maybe there's a journalist who's got 70
000 twitter followers and they're making
you know 30 to 50k a year off of being
an independent journalist well tim do
you think they can afford it
do you think it's psychologically two
people want to be liked by the new york
times or want their book reviewed is it
that
psychological effect they don't want to
take on an institution as revered as
beloved
what do you think about do you ever
wonder i was reading something that was
really interesting they talk about how
the old mythological stories of heroism
were
individuals challenging the system
fighting against the gods
and the superheroes of today are
supporting the system
and fighting on behalf of the
establishment so i i wondered about that
you have people right now that don't
want to challenge the machine no matter
how evil or wrong it may be no matter
how much they oppress
and harm the working class the little
guy the individual
they want to be a part of the machine
they want to be the one hazing the other
person not the one getting hazed
so when you look at the the the
unfettered power the new york times
where cnn has
to destroy lives why would anyone choose
to be on the other end of that
so i mean with them it's a legitimate
and i think the same
psychological effect has on people i've
noticed that since
project vertex has been banned i don't
want to share project
because i might be banned i want people
to draw an analogy that's like saying i
don't want to tell the truth because the
new york times might be mean to me
okay let's treat twitter like the new
york times don't draw a distinction
between big tech and big media they are
one and the same in fact the algorithms
prefer cnn right
well youtube creates a special section
on their front page for
carousel the establishment news outlets
you're not going to find
well you may get recommended shows like
this you may get recommended my other
channels which is news commentary
and journalism but cnn gets special
privilege and
what's funny is download vid iq i love
this plugin i use it
and it shows you a percentage next to
the title of every video video of the
thumbs up to thumbs down ratio
you'll see the recommended videos are
usually overwhelmingly
thumbs up well they're being recommended
it'll be videos from maybe me or steven
crowder or maybe people like kyle
kalinski depending on your politics or
jimmy dore
but then you'll see this special
mainstream media carousel and it's all
10 thumbs up five percent just
overwhelmingly rejected by the users of
youtube
but youtube desperate for the the
approval of cnn the new york times abc
etc drop to their knees
and beg cnn to like them beg yep i think
it's
fair to say as you were mentioning james
there that the mainstream media and
social media companies definitely share
the same activist toolkits as some
people would say
but this is interesting i think this is
the bigger story here the legal aspect
of it because if you remember not so
long ago cnn had to settle with the
covington
kids yes so there is a president
underscore this undisclosed we don't
know exactly how much but if
if that's the case that we don't know
how much that means it's it's a good
much it's it's a lot
not necessarily but i do want to address
that so i see a lot from the left
saying this was clearly a nuisance fee
they probably paid the bare minimum just
to make them go away i don't think
that's true
that's ironic i don't think that's true
though i don't because
uh i believe the the motion dismiss
failed
and they were potentially looking at
depositions and discovery right that
sounds to me
like the covington kids and their lawyer
probably said we don't need a nuisance
fee we can put more pressure on you
cnn probably they definitely didn't pay
250 million dollars to settle
but it probably was uh nice it's hard to
know that was the lawyer in that lynn
wood was the attorney for
that crazy but it's also the washington
post that settled thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time